[Music]
amanda bynes is reportedly back in
treatment the 32 year old actress
checked into a rehab facility in Los
Angeles in January and is getting help
for drug addiction along with mental
health issues
according to reports getting back into
Hollywood was just too much too soon for
the actress
[Music]
in November Amanda opened up the paper
magazine revealing she was four years
sober at the time she was studying at
the Fashion Institute of Design
merchandising and revealed she was ready
to get back into acting and excited for
her future quote what's there to lose I
have no fear of the future I've been
through the worst and came out the other
end and survived it so I just feel like
it's only up from here Amanda's last
film was easy a nearly a decade ago
listen I'm not the one that you have to
answer to for your depraved behavior
retired from acting Amanda became a
tabloid target for her erratic behavior
after she moved to New York City she
then went in and out of mental health
facilities in 2014 she revealed she was
diagnosed with bipolar disorder as of
now she remains under a conservatorship
by her parents
earlier this month et was with mantas
former Amanda Show co-star Drake Bell do
you think they would ever bring back the
Amanda show possibly I hope so Amanda
said she wants to get back into acting
and she's hysterical so that'd be
awesome no I haven't seen her in a while
you know
and last fall that cannon who she worked
with on all that said this five years
ago you wrote this open letter to amanda
bynes have you talked to her as of
recently I haven't but I heard she's
doing so much better and that's I mean
people when they're weird when they're
dealing with personal issues sometimes
you got to give him that space yeah and
then when they reach out then that's the
time to do it so she knows and you know
I always to open invite whenever she
needs anything I'm career or even
personally I'm here so I would love a
comeback yeah we wanted it we trying to
get her on wild and I we had to all that
reunion and that's kind of when I knew
like okay she still she's still working
on herself and which is an outstanding
thing but you know she's always welcome
that's a little sis right there
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]